okay
welcome to this meeting of the
mid-suffolk development control B
committee I am councilor Dave Muller and
I will be chairing the meeting today
may I first please read some domestic
Arrangements please do not interrupt
speakers or hold separate conversations
whilst others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones and
laptops are on silent
we will be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern.gov app so please
could members make sure they are logged
in and ready to use the app
the council members of the public and
the Press May record the film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the Press are not lawfully
excluded
I'd like to make some introductions we
have the area planning manager Gemma
Walker
the legal advisor Ian Duprey we have the
case officers we've got Jasmine wired
Daniel Cameron and Massa Cavani and the
governance officer is Alicia Norman can
I move to the agenda please item one
apologies for absence and substitutions
please
thank you chair we have apologies this
morning from councilor Guthrie with
councilor Humphrey substituting and we
also have apologies from councilor gold
with councilor had him substituting
thank you very much
item number two to receive any
Declarations of discloseable pecuniary
interests other registerable interests
or non-regitable interests by members
are there any uh councilor haddington
police and thanks I know the applicants
on um what's the first one now the
Davidsons and the noble Humphrey's son
oh right we'll use this one uh just
briefly I'm I'm obviously not here as
decision maker I'm as your advice I'm
just going to say I'm sure a few people
saw me say hello to the agent for Mr
Rankin who
is the Fanning's Farm application we
knew each other that worked together in
local government in another place a few
years ago but that won't stop either was
doing our job Focus today but I thought
I'd better just mention it
being already to declare
yes I've had one
okay
very much thank you very much
chair we should declare which
application we've been here
item C yes 7c everyone seven and the one
I had was merci Davidson Limited
yep same one okay thank you very much
okay decorations of personal site visits
no
okay item five confirmation of the
minutes of the meeting held on the 1st
of February 2023 are there any points
regarding the accuracy of the minutes
no okay could I have a proposer please
thank you councilor um Norris I think
you were first and the second to please
councilor Caston I now ask the
governance officer can you please
conduct the electronic votes thank you
we chair that vote is now in progress
Council of all boys do you want me to
take your vote verbally because it's not
come through for me
that's fine
thank you
thank you chair so that makes six votes
four and two abstentions that's carried
I'll now move on to item six to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
Devon I'll now start with the schedule
planning applications we will be hearing
item 7c first and then we'll have seven
seven a and then 7B in in that order so
7c is DC 21
06824 land at fenings Farm pixie green
stradbrok and I'd now like to invite the
case officer mashik kavani to introduce
the application to the committee thank
you Masha
cool
so just one second I think we're having
fun technical issues
on track now
thank you
the application site is situated in the
countryside and the proposal is for the
expansion of an existing poetry
operation at fenings Farm
proposal includes six number of poetry
houses with Associated admin blocks feed
bins and ancillary development
this shows The Wider context of the site
within the countryside there are no
immediate residential neighbors with the
exception of those which are associated
with the farm operations
the location
Ally public footpath near the site to
the east
and is the slide shows the land in the
ownership of the applicant and also the
access
the form would be accessed why it exists
in farm access which already serves the
existing sheds and Farm
ing's Farm also hosts the builders yard
as well as the Poultry Farm the
surrounding land is used largely for
arable farming
this slide shows the location of the
only Heritage assets within close
proximity and it shows the distances to
the side
this slide shows the location of the
residential neighbors closest to the
side
the ones outlining purple shows the
properties that are already associated
with the farm operations
this slide shows the other residential
Neighbors which are within close
proximity of the side
noise and odor amongst other
environmental impacts are regulated by
the environmental agency
permittent regime
the application is accompanied by
industry standard relevant surveys
this slide shows the building
the buildings will be purpose-built
steel framed structures
the units are set back from the road
with minimal visual impact
as noted earlier the only vantage point
to the development is the public
footpath to the east
as you can see there is some Landscaping
already proposed for the site
which surrounds the units new units
and also shows the location of the
existing units
these are some photos from the site this
is a protein from the West as you can
see the site is heavily surrounded by
existing trees and vegetation
and any kind of views would be
obstructed by the existing the
structures on site
such as this minor visual impact as a
result of the development
we have also been provided with some
drone photos by the applicant we chose
the wider context of the site and also
shows how
it's encapsulated by already existing
Landscapes around in the site
and this is another photo of the
existing units
proposed units would be similar in a
stylus scale and Design
albeit be better Better Built and modern
this is an agricultural development
supported by our local plan policies and
in ppf and as such is supported in
principle
proposal is also an eia development
it is regulated by the environmental
permitting regime
regime the application is accompanied by
a comprehensive environmental statement
noise impact assessment and so on
it is the Environmental permitting
regulations that deals with the use
treatment of storage and disposal of
waste and emissions from industrial
processes this includes noise and odor
all technical matters including highways
and ecology have been subject to
consultation with our statutory
consultees and no objections have been
raised subject to conditions
matters of water usage including wash
water and drinking water have also been
subject to discussions and consultations
with Essex and Suffolk water
their response concludes that the
proposal is acceptable subject to the
recommended condition
based on this assessment and based on
the recommendation from our expert
colleagues the application is
recommended for approval subject to
condition
thank you chair
thank you very much Master do we have
questions for the planning officer
Council Stringer please just want to go
back on you said that there were no
objections
uh but there are objections on the case
File are they not
so the the Water Authority is not a
statutory consultee
they are
and they did not object yeah
they have raised concerns and they have
given us their position however they
said to overcome their objections they
recommended a grampian
so they then was objections
yes yeah yes right okay thank you
53 below the first paragraph there's an
officer note yeah I couldn't has
informed the officers they'll provide
Clarity on matters of water ahead of
committee
has that been received
so just give me one second
yes so um I have had recent
correspondence with the agent with the
applicant and they have providers
further further information in terms of
they would be happy to agree another
condition in terms of water usage on
site which I'm happy to read to the
members but this has also been uploaded
on our website
it's public documentation
thank you fun I think I must have just
answered this this grumpy and condition
about the scheme for water neutrality
this is something that we've got to
um work out the terms of in in this
meeting
this
is offer further clarification but this
is something that is going to have to be
agreed before the operation is in use
okay
um my second question is about the waste
water and
um there's some discussion in the
documents about the sort of number of
journeys of
um and there's questions being raised
about where it's actually going to go is
that reasonable for us to ask that this
is specified Within
application
this matter is dealt with by the
environment
today the Wastewater from the
application from The Proposal
um I can redo something from the
environmental statement that we have
been provided by the applicant and it's
been undefiled that might be helpful
so the surface water drainage system
would drain clean surface water runoff
only when the 40 houses and access are
cleaned a diverter valve with director
wash down water into sealed below ground
holding tanks to be removed from the
site and disposed of by license washing
contractors
at the end of each six to eight week
growing period broilers will be removed
from the houses we've used litter taken
away from the farm in converted trailers
and the empty houses will then be
powered power washed disinfected and
ready for the arrival of the next crop
at this point outflow from the
Subterranean water storage tank would be
stopped and the Wastewater subsequently
exported from the farm in a sealed tank
loads
licensed operators that's that's right
that's right thank you
then I will move on to the public
speakers and first I'd like to introduce
the parish council odile Laden please
hopefully opinates that right apologies
if I didn't you have three minutes
morning it's Odell vladon thank you
thank you horn and athenington denim
stradbroke parish councils and I Town
Council have all submitted concerns
regarding this application
the impact on the parishes will be
different but the concerns do highlight
the need to review The Wider
implications of developments which form
part of the supply chain for a larger
industry
stradbroke Parish Council supports
development in fact the neighborhood
plan contains proposals for over 250 new
homes
the plan also has policies which support
the expansion of commercial activities
however the parish council is clear all
proposals brought forward must be
sustainable and must comply with the
policies in the plan the parish council
has reviewed the documentation
supporting this application and found
that the reports are lacking in full
detail and do not reflect the
application as it stands today
the area assessed for the ecology report
does not include the site for the
proposed Reservoir the County Council
require a surface water management plan
but the one included in the flood risk
report is out of date as it was written
before the water mitigation proposals
the noise impact assessment fails to
reference the existing section 106
agreement in place it does not assess
the noise from the proposed heat
exchanges and seems to indicate that
there will be no increase in hgvs
the ammonia and odor assessments both
note that heat exchangers will be fitted
to the proposed and existing units yet
the plan only shows them installed
against the proposed a 29 reduction in
ammonium emissions has been applied in
calculations but it is unclear why as
the applicant hasn't decided which heat
exchanger to use
the reports still do not comply with the
current case law with regards to the
management of both Wastewater and manure
there are no plans submitted that show
how the rain water harvesting will be
retrofitted to the existing units or how
the surface water drainage will be
reworked given the environment a
environment agency statement issued on
the 10th of February that the region
remains in drought the parish council is
concerned whether there will in fact be
sufficient rainfall to fill the
reservoir
the applicant states that the local the
location avoids encroachment into the
wider agricultural unit and the loss of
grade three good quality agricultural
land by citing adjacent to existing farm
buildings
however this is no longer the case as
the site has become larger given the
requirements for a reservoir and
Associated filtration equipment
this proposal does not comply with the
policy strad 11 and 13 and is noted by
Place Services is not in accordance with
mppf paragraph 206. any contribution
this development may make to the public
economy would also be available in a
more sustainable location the parish
council notes that a proposal for 20
units at the Airfield at methwold is
being considered by West Norfolk
District Council
this is a more sustainable location and
we bring forward the same tangible
assets the parish council reiterates the
subjection and recommends refusal
thank you Mr use the word sustainable my
question is this
um
I can't find why it's not sustainable
why do you feel it's not sustainable
but the waste management isn't properly
clarified in accordance with the Squire
versus Shropshire case or the Keating
versus
West East Suffolk case there is
absolutely no the the the policy the
documents submitted are not up to date
and do not reflect what you're
considering today
it's just to come back actually and ask
you if you question
able actually means
to be able to maintain at a certain rate
or level
is that what you're trying to say sorry
are you saying that it can't be
maintained at a certain rate or level
which what sustainable means I don't
believe the water can no okay thank you
thanks for having them please I'd really
like to know what Masha has to say to um
in answer if that is allowed
well
the question of how to use it has been
subject to many discussions with the
applicant
um and also Essex and Suffolk water
so we have a condition here the doesn't
allow the operation to go ahead without
being fulfilled
it's that grampian condition
so basically the applicant needs needs
to demonstrate that the operation is
water neutral
and with that in mind
we are happy to support it as officers
um
because if that condition can be
fulfilled there's no other reason to to
hold the up hold approval thank you
am I allowed to ask a question of the
officer because that extra bit of
information so the the amount of vehicle
movements to achieve water
sustainability
because you've been talking about
holding tanks and all this stuff you
know when the things wash down
etc etc and obviously these birds have
got a drink and all this kind of stuff
um
have those
do we know how many vehicle movements it
will take to achieve water
sustainability and has that vehicle
number
been accounted for in the traffic
assessment
um I can check that thank you councilor
I can check that but what I can tell you
that the finer details of that condition
we don't know yet we don't know exactly
how but we know that this is a
pre-commencement condition so the
details will come forward before the
development is then commenced
and also in terms of total number of
traffic generated as a result of the
development has been calculated as 4.7
percent
so with the existing operation when
these six units are added the total
number of call generated as a result
would be 447 which is not a significant
number
so you have calculated the amount of
vehicle movements it will take to hit
because you calculated at 4.7 I don't
understand
you're telling us that you don't know
how many vehicles it will take to
achieve water sustainability
but you say you have calculated the
vehicle number and it's 4.7 percent
in relation to
how the
neutrality
that that detail we don't know but in
terms of the traffic as a result of the
development in terms of HIV movements
and deliveries and so on and so forth
this has been extensively explored in
the transport management
um but in terms of water how water
neutrality can be achieved that is how
we don't know yet so that's something
that has to be achieved pre-commense you
can just qualify that may involve more
than four point whatever percent of
vehicle movements extra
ction management
sure um so question for the public
speaker
um you mentioned uh stride 13 which is
one of the um
one of the parts of your of your labor
plan and you said that this proposal
does not
the requirements of that in what
particular respects were you referring
will stride 13 has um as its first
bullet point the proposals are not
significantly detrimental to the
character of The Wider Countryside or
the views across it
and place Services have acknowledged
that that is the case
um we still maintain the Parish Schools
perhaps Parish Council still maintains
that the highways are affected however
the um
information from the highways Authority
is so vague it's very hard to prove the
impact that two hgvs mounting the
pavement outside the primary school
that that would have a severe or
significant impact because apparently
it's an arbitrary number that somebody
thinks of at the time they're assessing
a planning application there's no
absolute definitive rule to follow so we
still believe that there is an impact on
the highway which is contrary to mppf
110 highways do not
questions
no
okay thank you very much we'll then move
on to the objector Tanya Farrow please
and you've got three minutes as well
thank you
I'm Council attorney Farrow chair of
Denham Parish Council denim Mill which
is cited in this application is located
on the denim Hawks and Boundary the
parish council objected to this
application primarily on the grounds of
the detrimental impact of the additional
volume of hgv traffic however the
objection is not included in the
planning committee report and we felt it
was important to highlight that the
industrial operations of this kind have
clear planning impacts beyond the
immediate vicinity of the site
denim Mill has been subject to a
planning contravention notice based on a
suspected material change of use the
planning enforcement investigation has
not yet concluded the mill is classified
as agricultural
Brunswick PLC who leased the mill
applied for an environmental permit to
significantly increase output from the
mill in April 2020 the H1 environmental
impact assessment for the payment permit
started stated that they would be around
100 hgv movements per day surveys
conducted by residents estimate that
this boat this figure is more than
double the previous number of HG
movement movements and it has already
been reached
since the mail operations changed the
parish council has received multiple
complaints about traffic incidents on
the narrow rural roads including near
accidents with all manner of Road users
as well as damage to roads verges and
traffic congestion
the parish council would like to make
the following points the environmental
statement states that 30 percent of the
feed will come from Denham Mill however
it states that this is an estimate and
the actual figure could be significantly
higher it should also be noted that the
hgv movement cited only relates to the
number of additional trips to the mail
and then onwards defending's Farm there
will be an Associated increase in hgv
movements due to the increased volume of
raw materials to provide these
additional feeds these have not been
accounted for in the environmental
statement and all the planning committee
report
the transport assessment for this
application States it should be noted
that Dena Mill operates a one-way system
with traffic routing in by a Hobson and
leaving via horum towards fenning's farm
this is not factually correct and does
not happen in practice the operator of
the mill has stated they cannot enforce
this leading to much wider Highway and
Immunity impacts outside of denim
including horumpoxin and stradbroke
the same document has an assessment of
personal injury which only looks at two
points along the Route whereas further
inspection of the same website shows
that they're in the same five-year
period there were two serious incidents
along the Chickering Road this is a
common access point for the denim Feed
Mill
this application has raised concerns
about water usage and there is currently
a moratorium from Essex and Suffolk
water for new non-domestic users in the
um hartus mere Water Resource Zone as
part of repurposing the mill the
production process was changed from dry
Millet to feed
um to pellet feed production which
involves in the use of steam in the
conditioning process within this
application the planning officer has not
adequately considered the in combination
effects of the proposed increased feed
production to support the additional
birds in conclusion denim Parish Council
objects to this planning application on
the basis that it does not represent
sustainable development the adverse
impacts on neighboring parishes
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits of this application and the
council asked the committee they use it
very much do we have any questions
please for Tanya Farrow
County home then councilor melon please
for the speaker or for Masher but on
page 65 we've got a map and it's showing
that the the route to the feed mill is
nine
um Laurie today are you saying that it's
going to be more
that's the maximum they're talking about
um
so I'm saying that on the basis of that
that's literally just talking about the
movements to um from there to the farm
obviously that's going to result in an
increase in feed production necessary to
support those units and none of the
assessment of that has been included so
you know we're obviously increasing the
production of feed from that Mill and
that's going to increase the number of
hgv movements so you're not saying there
is going to be more than nine you're not
I'm saying this is wrong you're just
saying that I could say the evidence
isn't there to suggest that everything's
being considered in that assessment
um yeah I'm not sure if this is a
question for
um
the officer or maybe for Ian I'm not
sure um so where the implications of an
application affect a site outside of the
boundary of the application
how do we how do we have to consider
that as as
a planning committee
sorry I've been quite catch the question
if you don't mind repeating I mean
clearly what we've just heard is about
this mostly about the site of denim Mill
which is not part of the red line
boundary so how do we how do we have to
take that into account I'm just asking
for some guidance really
always begin to go fast please
I think what will you you will consider
the the effect if you
if you can your decision you can
know very well all members as committee
know very well the statutory test about
policy and material considerations you
will consider the if the impact of
granting this decision
generally
so
there may be a point I mean if the point
was about
well I was I was making notes and
listening I
I I'm not altogether sure I've got the
full
um
text as it were of the the concern that
was expressed about
was it about a combination of this
permission of his granted and activities
on another site was that how you were to
study Council melon yeah um clearly the
the feed mill
it's ancillary to this but it's not in
the location
that we're dealing with
so I'm just trying to understand how
how much
a concern about an off-site operation
should
here
I'm making myself true yes I think it's
quite clear you are talking about a
cumulative impact of of the development
yes we have to consider that as a
planning matter as well so we have to
look at a wider picture to see what
other operations are in the area
um
this is an agricultural development
it's it's a well-established scene and
activity in in the countryside
the traffic surrounding Phoenix Farms
it's low it's not a highly trafficked
road the road network is low it's part
of Suffolk Lorry root
um already so what we are here to
consider is that what is the increase
and is it significant and dangerous
enough for us to to refuse it based on
that and based on the evidence that
we've been provided crash map data and
Suffolk County Council highways
no there's no evidence to suggest that
this development would lead to a
significant harm and a danger
onto the road Network or will generate
such traffic that is going to be so
significant that it's going to be
significantly harmful and should be
refused based on that I think that might
answer your question
is that helpful
thank you
uh there is there is another reason why
you might want to take all information
into account and that's by uh making
sure you've got the correct conditions
on any approval so it isn't just shall
we refuse or shall we approve it you can
approve with conditions and in fact it
suggested a grampian condition here and
grampian conditions are for areas
outside of the red line
so are we well I mean that's my
understanding of a grampian condition uh
I think perhaps we all ought to probably
understand what they mean before we
look at imposing one I thought that
grabbing Edition was for land outside of
the red line there's one proposed here
so is this document suggesting we can
impose conditions upon a meal or
whatever that's not part of the redline
application site I think we perhaps need
to know that before we
yeah so we can fully understand what our
role is here today thank you
thanks Master no that's fine um yeah so
on a couple of those bits really so in
terms of The Wider impact yes you can
consider the wider impact you know when
we think highways we do have to take
about the network so there is that wider
implication there is that cumulative
impact we can look at there is a degree
of caution if we are looking at one
specific feed mill we can't restrict the
um
manage your own occupy of printing Farm
to using that feed mill so there is
always going to be some degree of
differences with what they do use and
what they could use but yes in general
the cumulative impact of the traffic
could be relevant to the consideration
so yes there are some
issues there that we would need to
consider cumulatively in terms of the
grampian condition so we can require
works on land that's not controlled by
the applicant or that it might require
consent of another person or body
that that sometimes fails the test of
reasonableness but we can put that
condition on in essentially a negative
form that's two ramping conditions
you're stopping development authorized
by the Planning Commission
until something has taken place so in
this case what we're saying is that the
diamond can't take place until we have
got the scheme for water neutrality now
we shouldn't use the conditions where
there's no Prospect of this happening so
um kind of a good example at this time
but if we didn't think that a water
neutrality scheme was possible
then there would be a not a reasonable
condition however what we're seeing and
the information that we've had so far
and in discussion with Essex and Suffolk
water is that the suggestion is there is
enough information and enough reasonable
certainty that they could provide
for the water neutrality by the various
measures are set out in the condition
from Essex and Suffolk water in order to
provide that neutral position so sorry
that was a bit of two answers but
hopefully that covered both points
any further questions
okay thank you very much Tanya I now
like to move on to supporter Matthew
Ward please you two have three minutes
thank you very much
a bit of background so I'm a director of
crown
uh I've been in there since 1985 so I
wanted done the history
the history of the business and the
growth of the industry
uh we sold out to cransway because you
know 2016 and the brand new factories
were built in 2019.
uh to operate that we operate out of
something like 75 locations 20 of those
are breeding farms
50 55 of those are the broiler Farms one
of which is the farming question at
fretting field
Davison family had been and are very
important in our in our chain because
they develop sites for us and very
instrumental in the improvements in shed
design that we that we want for a modern
a modern chicken growing world
what I would say the sites the sites
that we've developed in the last five
ten years are in a different League to
what was done in the 70s and the 80s
and by what do I mean by that I do mean
the heat recovery the modern sites are
using 50 of the energy to heat them
and compared to the really old sites I
would actually say it's five-fold and by
that I mean the old Breeze box sites
that have just about all gone now
uh
heat we've just gone through last year
those two days of 40 degrees C
we've had modern sheds and I can tell
you where they take out 10 degrees C and
those birds stayed alive
not a issue you can't really retrofit
those in Old facilities we need modern
facilities to be competitive
uh
the water rainwater harvesting is being
rolled out on on these modern sites and
that is the way the way to go and how
some of this will be tackled
uh because
biosecurity the drainage the modern
sites you've heard about tanks that's
all part of modern sites
which which is is what we need for the
future
why do we need these sites
one one of the things that's not been
mentioned so far is you have all seen in
the press the uh better chicken
commitment bbcc we are being uh
let down that route you know the
supermarkets are are wanting a
commitment what does that mean to us it
means a stocking rate reduction from 38
kg maximum to 30 kg
it's 21 reduction
so we're going to stay as significant
today
and meet the BCC commitment we need more
space
uh so what I'm saying is this is not all
about expansion
so in terms of do we need more feed
because of this no we don't we don't
Place more chicks we don't Mill more
food it's about
keeping us sustainable with the space
that we've got
thank you
thank you very much
um
explain the relationship groundswick has
with this site is it
and I've got a bit confused is it your
site or
are you in so we are we we
of the we look after it so we rent it
the Davidsons build sites we rent sites
yeah but they are very
in East and angling not just for us
other firms as well we developed these
modern uh systems and it's the last
three four years on cooling these sheds
has been a change it's a different world
and we have to say the summer we've just
had we were very successful in what
we've done and so there's um there's no
chance that any of the feed would come
out of a different Mill it's not about
expansion we went no Mill expansion yeah
no but I mean you the the unit wouldn't
change its feed provider it's always
right it's your site your mail is always
going to come from yeah okay thank you
very much
yeah
um just want to understand about
um
uh clearly that's a good thing but just
is that for for the chickens to drink I
mean is that something that works in
this age of you know biosecurity and and
bird flu yeah so we have about I think
in our business there's about three
sites where rodent water harvesting
works and yeah it's from the drink but
obviously it's treated
so it's yeah it goes into a reservoir
but then before it's pumped around the
site it is treated
and um
you said that this is not about
expansion so you're going to knock down
the old sheds because they know I don't
know we need more space to give the
chickens more space so the stocking rate
so there won't be any more chickens
going through than
what you have at the moment it will be
on that farm yes
you'll need more feed for more chickens
no
no the amount of birds we place we place
on that site on that site of course we
will because it's it's a big expansion
right so it's a slightly different to
what you said a minute ago which is that
you won't be needing more food so the
stocking rates if if we go down the
better chicken and we have got we have
got sites in our business which are
stocks for us in the microphone which I
stopped for BCC at 30k kg so if the
industry moves this way
we need 20 25 more space
the same numbers
yeah okay I understand that about the
wider industry I think we're just trying
to deal with this site
and I think from what you said there
will be an expansion there'll be yeah so
more feed will be going to that farm
right yes
thank you chat
I think councilor Mellon just extracted
the answer I was trying to get
okay
I do um have a question on the total
um feed storage capacity on the site but
should I wait for the applicant or
should I ask that question now shall I
shall I ask that after the applicants
I'll wait till the applicant thanks
any further questions at all
no thank you very much indeed Mr Ward
therefore I now like to call the agent
Mr Johnny Rankin please and you two have
three minutes
good morning members of the planning
committee
with thanks to the officer for the
comprehensive presentation
as you will have seen within the
committee report we have worked with the
planning officer
and the relevant consultees to ensure
that there are no significant
environmental impacts arising from The
Proposal
this is reflected in the lack of any
objections from statutory consultants
and the officer's recommendation of
approval
the operational sheds at felling's farm
feed into the regional poultry Network
inclusive of the crownswick processing
planted eye
the regional Network employs more than 1
500 people in and around mid-suffolk
including at the processing plant feed
mills and Farm
there is also a host of other businesses
in the area which are reliant on the
poultry industry to sustain their levels
of employment
a key example of this would be the
poultry house construction business
owned and operated by the applicant the
business employs over 60 people full
time with over 40 of those living in
mid-suffolk
members will also be aware of ongoing
food shortages from eggs to solid items
more recently homegrown food production
in sustainable locations such as
felling's Farm will avoid
future shortages of chicken
in compliance with the mppf The Proposal
will allow for the existing Farm
operation to grow resulting in three
full-time managers and part-time staff
the parish council have raised concerns
in respect of Highways and odor whilst
we understand the council's reasons for
raising concerns we do not believe they
are founded and it is worth reiterating
the operation on nine sheds are not
subject to complaint or causing highways
issues
both the environmental health officer
and the County Council highways officer
have reviewed the proposed sheds and
have responded with no objection
Essex and Suffolk War to raise concerns
in respect of water supply
the applicant and planning officers have
met with Essex Pacific water to ensure
their concerns are addressed this has
resulted in the rainwater harvesting
condition as set out in the officer's
report to committee
as well as a comprehensive environmental
impact assessment accompanying the
application
the applicant has discussed and is
agreeable to all the conditions set out
in the officer's report
adding further controls and assurances
to any planning consent granted
with thanks for your consideration today
and we respectfully request that you
resolve to approve the application in
line with the officer's recommendation
the applicant and myself are here and
happy to answer any questions you may
have
I'll do that question now then on this
just on the new site what would be the
um total
um
in tongues
um capacity for storing feed I've seen
the
um the shed on there it looks like each
shed has three nine ton bins or so but
um could you just tell me how much
yeah sure so as you pointed to there is
uh grain silos on plan on would be
approved plans and tonnage wise
28 tons in the nine uh silos
apologies 28 in each bin yeah okay yeah
I was going to say 20 that wouldn't even
get you for a day on the new site but um
so is there anything um the second
question is there any barriers to
abstracting water for this site and um
any barriers to license abstraction
yes in a word yes and that is the basis
of the grampian condition
um we met with Essex and Civic water in
the hearts mere Zone there's effectively
a
a monitorium on any further extraction
licenses that's why you say you see the
the grampian condition
and that is to make sure that rainwater
harvesting meets the demands meets the
supply required now
the operational sheds or not they don't
have harvesting a present it's something
that operationally the applicant and
crans week are deploying so we know
we've got a
appropriate surface area there is an
attenuation pond on plan
our homework if you like to fulfill that
condition is to ensure that
that rainwater harvesting means the
supply put short if we can't do that and
I should say we're utterly assured we
can
and then we can't build the sheds that's
the nature of the condition so it's a
very high level of assurance for for the
parish for members of this committee
thank you
yeah thank you uh I I think it would
have been really helpful because I know
we're going through a raging of trying
not to put too much paper in front of
members but I think it would have been
really helpful if we'd have had the
original objection from the Water
Authority because all of the questions
that we're asking are in that objection
uh and that would have been really
helpful uh that side the so we're going
to harvest rain water to basically feed
and wash the site because we wash it
every six to eight weeks
so how many days will the Lagoon
uh last fall if we have a drought as we
had last year
well um
if you built the Lagoon in drought
conditions it wouldn't last for any days
yeah we're hoping to build it before
any drought condition and obviously
taking advantage of the preceding
rainfall
so if you started with a zero Baseline
zero but that again would be an
operational problem you wouldn't fill
the sheds without the laguben in situ
and there's a condition that requires
that yes I understand that what I didn't
ask the question correctly assume you
build the Lagoon assuming we get enough
rainfall to fill it
assume then it stops raining like it did
last year how many days will that Lagoon
last
circumstantial
but it could last several crops it won't
go on indefinitely no no you know it's
it's an impossible question to answer at
this stage is it
like I can't tell you
in point a when that Lagoon's in situan
full I can't then tell you but it will
be a requirement of the applicant to
have water for those birds they couldn't
put birds in there if they couldn't keep
them watered
no I I totally understand that I
I find it I find it difficult that you
don't know the water use we know we know
and have submitted that there was use
explicitly
it's all before you're in the submitted
documents
um
yeah but put simply operation can't
continue if there isn't enough water for
the birds
yeah I I get that I totally understand
that I was just trying to seek how long
the Lagoon proposed would run the site
for in terms of washing and feeding the
birds and watering the birds am I not
being clear well I'm trying to ascertain
these because if the Lagoon is empty and
you're running you'll be tankering water
in and out that's what that's how Water
Works our local Water Works has two
Lorry movements a day just to keep it
topped up and I'm and if we're in an
area that has no water it's quite simple
yeah we're in an area where the Water
Authority is saying we do not have
enough water to sustain this application
yeah and I'm just trying to work out are
we then is the Lagoon Gonna Last a year
if it's full great for every single
thing to do with the operation or might
it last a few months and then we have to
revert to tankers bringing water in and
out yeah so water isn't tankered in for
for drinking there's an existing water
supply the Lagoon would have a capacity
of Sixteen thousand meters squared with
an annual usage requirement of twelve
thousand uh
Square cubed apologies so there is in
that Lagoon alone in excess of the
requirement for the operation of the
site
taking that snapshot measurement
just to clarify the existing side has
obviously water supply more than
sufficient to serve the existing site
and to a point the proposed the water
Lagoon is is to add contingency if you
like
thank you very much Jim this question in
regards to um dead birds if you um
that's the site could easily operate a
four percent loss on dead birds if God
forbid something happened it could be
more it's quite a considerable number
with the numbers that we're running of
chickens in the shed um you know
up to a hundred thousand a year if um
that four percents for each flock
um that's in turnover
um what
um what provision is there on this site
to um to deal with those
um the dead birds that are gradually
produced as a as a byproduct of this
as per the report
you know dead stock is is taken away
those traffic numbers are included
within the transport assessment
there's some more detail you wanted so
it's really the storage of the dead
birds from the moment they're picked out
of the sheds to um to being brought and
put onto lorries and taken away which
obviously won't be an instant process
it's almost impossible for it to be an
instant process I'll just confirm that
but I believe they're in called store
effectively okay right yeah
cold star and then taken away in
the relevant collection
yeah okay and um the second question
when a um when feeds delivered to the
site it'd be maybe delivered by an
arctic
um is the room for that Arctic to turn
around
and um would it go would it go around
all the sheds and come down because from
the map that I've seen it doesn't look
like it's absolutely easy for an Arctic
to turn around deliver food and then
turn around and leave the where it came
in could you just it might help if they
put the map up
for that would that be possible
does this help
um
the um the plan of the new one should be
yeah there so um it it doesn't seem
absolutely obvious where an articulated
Lorry would go because it looks quite
tight for it to go around
the sheds and obviously there's two
types of feed delivery there's your
articulated Lorry and you there's your
rigid Lorry but obviously this site
would probably be better with
articulated lorries
so effective
ly circulate within the site
up over the top and back out all the way
around all the sheds and out the bottom
yes is there enough space there to turn
yes obviously that was tracked on the
um design layout and
most importantly including the transport
assessment um without staying the
obvious year vehicles can circulate from
from all the businesses and out of the
site yeah I think it's probably down to
the scale of the drawing that it looks a
lot smaller than it actually is but yeah
thank you very much
thank you chair I'm sorry I'm going to
come back to the rainwater harvesting
um
you mentioned that the existing site
doesn't actually have a rainwater
harvesting scheme
so what they the new rainwater
harvesting scheme service the whole of
the site
the the issue is
um Essex and Civic water granting new
supplies
the operational Farm doesn't need new
Supply but obviously the Poultry Farm
the shed building business the other
business on site represent catchment you
know that's untapped at the moment
before you go on to the you know land
drains on The Wider Farm
so um yes it has been pointed to
rainwater harvesting is something that's
been employed in the same way that solar
panels are you know just to improve
efficiency of the running of sites
so the the right scheme the whole site
could be water neutral
rainwater could be harvested across the
site it's all within the ownership it's
all operational yes
okay thank you
no
okay thank you very much Mr Rankin uh
when they move on to the ward member
councilor Julie flatman please thank you
thank you thank you chair
Davidsons are a limited
um construction business and they also
specialize in the development of poultry
sites throughout Norfolk and Suffolk
so this site is very important it
they're their own customer they're going
to be building their own shares
they employ
63 to 40 people
the surrounding Workforce
all comes mainly from The Villages
around
in this day and age with the cost of
living crisis
what's going to happen if we don't
employ local people for local rural
business
I could probably name you know 50 people
who have already worked there and still
have children work there
the site is huge there is more than
enough room for juggernauts Etc to turn
around there they're a building business
they store their wood Etc there
the
the problem we have with the roads we
all know there is a problem with lorries
with delivery of small Goods as well
years ago our roads were used for horse
and carts let's face it are we going to
stop all production are we going to stop
all farming no we're not
we import
408 metric tons of poultry leads we
import it there is not enough chicken in
this country we've had the avian flu so
many
shades are empty at this time at a time
when we need cheap sustainable meat
what made young families buy poultry
they can't afford a 14 pound free-range
chicken they buy chicken
three for a tenor it used to be I think
it's two for eight now because obviously
the cost of living's gone up
what have we done with the water the
water Essex and Suffolk they've been
raking in money they haven't actually
put in the infrastructure we can still
have 150 houses built in stradbroke but
we can't keep
a really well established local business
going no
defra have got a job on their hands
getting involved with this and make the
water companies invest invest the money
they've taken from everyone else that's
the problem they haven't done any
infrastructure and I hope Jeff are going
to get on the top of it now I will be
supporting thank you committee
no
no okay no questions thank you very much
councilor flattman therefore we open up
for the debate please who would like to
kick off the debate
thanks for Stringer yeah I'll kick this
one off
I find this one really really difficult
because on the one hand we have a water
company
who I have to say rarely
consult uh and and you know push the
envelope here and they've been quite
explicit
we do not have sufficient Water
Resources to meet the non-household
demand of this development proposal
and we recommend planting patients be
refused and a gramping condition is used
to as a Prelude to obligations being
entered into so they're being quite
they've set the bar incredibly High to
say look we we cannot service any extra
here and I I agree that there isn't this
isn't 100 addition because of the all
changing in in space standards it will
eat into some of this this shed space
however we're also being asked that we
need to enter into a condition that
conditions all hgv delivery and traffic
movements yet we don't know what they
are
because we don't know the exact regime
uh that the the Water Resource here will
need of us
because that that hasn't been bottomed
out yet
so we're in somewhat a Gillian knot here
we're being asked to approve planning
permission with the grampian condition
but we don't know all the details of
that condition I would like to see that
those obligations have been met and I
agree uh patch the water company and the
and haven't done their job historically
but it's our job here to make sure that
what we do approve here is sustainable
and we're at a point here where it's
with what we've already got in our plans
we've used all the water
so we're now having to you know jump
through all enormous Loops extend
planning applications to put lagoons in
to capture water
and equally I'd like to see exactly how
that's going to work because
whether we like it or not we're entering
extremes of of what the weather gets up
to in terms of dryness and also flash
flooding and if we're holding stuff in
tanks that that is also been used for
washing I'd like to make sure that
doesn't enter a Watercourse which there
is running straight through this site
according to the plans so I would have
liked to have seen an awful lot more
detail in here before I said yes so for
me is there enough here to refuse no I
personally would defer this until we've
seen the detail thank you
Mr chair thank you um we'll talk about a
couple of things just so we're clear the
first thing is a grumpy and condition
the grumpy and condition there's a bit
of talk about outside the red line area
um actually we're talking about cramping
commit grampian condition being applied
to the water supply and um and just so
we're clear on what grampian condition
is because I'm sure some people aren't
clear
um the expression derives from a
grampian Regional Council versus City of
Aberdeen and Bay supervisor condition
precluding the implementation of a
development permitted by a planning
permission until some step has been
taken is valid and what that means is if
you go to the water element which is
what the grampian condition is actually
about in this it says unless you satisfy
this condition to supply this water
either by rainfall harnessing or bore
holes or whatever else is mentioned
within this clear report then you won't
go anywhere so that's what the grampian
condition is for that's where it's been
used for and that I think gives us the
confidence that unless that mad that
this wouldn't take place so that's a
good thing first of all to make it
sustainable to prove the sustainability
to add the to have the implementation of
whatever system you come up with the
water for for the water storage in place
before it's actually allowed to continue
so that's the first bit about the
grampian condition I did ask about
sustainability it's used a lot here
sustainable it's not sustainable no one
ever says what's sustainable actually
mean well I've already stated it it
means and particularly in this in this
condition that effectively
um I'm going to find it because we've
got loads of notes because I've listened
to loads here that effectively that um I
want to find a thing bear with me I've
lost my my lost my grip so sustainable
it means as said before
um
able to upheld or defended able to be
maintained at a certain rate or level
well guess what
um it can be as long as the grampian
condition is in place and that water
supply comes in then this is definitely
sustainable and I don't think you can
argue against that it's a fact Because
unless we have it it's not sustainable
with it with the gramping condition it
becomes sustainable it can support and
it can support right now can't it so
it's already sustainable with the growth
they've already explained that you've
got more capacity than actually required
by four so that's a good thing as well
and we'll carry on with a sustainability
bit we're talking about business
sustainability so at the moment this
business wants to monitor modernize and
it wants to grow that's fantastic as the
world member said we were talking about
employment we're talking about our drive
to save the planet so instead of
importing millions and millions of
chickens let's grow our own let's make
them local let's take them local that's
exactly what we're doing so it's
sustainable in that case as well but
only if this is allowed to go through
and the business modifies and expands
because without it the business is not
sustainable
and actually like so we look at our
environmental pledge that's not
sustainable either unless we support
local business local growth and allow
these things to go through we'll talk
about the area the area itself is
suitable for this it's already doing the
job that it's doing and that's planned
for the future so I think that's a good
thing as well we talked about traffic
talk about highways but I've read this
paper and highways say and amasha you
made the point that unless this is
really dangerous what's the problem well
I can't find anything in here apart from
some subjective views and they are
really to to say there's not that it's
more dangerous than it is now it is what
it is we can't make bigger roads they
are what they are and actually people
don't drive there at 60 miles an hour
because they can't so of course we're
going to be more more trucks but
actually it's not going to make it any
more dangerous on the things that I've
read here including the crash map so I
think that that argument's out as well I
just want to cover a couple more points
before I finish if you don't mind
um
call Direct support talk about
sustainability I've done all that
um
yeah
I think I could most things
but I would like to summarize to say
this is great it's great because we're
actually seeing a business that's
willing to grow is willing to modernize
is willing to willing to think about the
environment as a whole an effect on the
local area I don't see any more effect
than there is now I can go down the odor
if you want where the wind comes from
Southwestern or in the south of England
so therefore all the odors taken away
from most of the population that live in
that area so we can go on and on and on
can't we the point I'm trying to make is
I can't find anything to hear that would
actually refuse this application I don't
think we need any more information and I
think the purpose of this committee is
to make a decision and uh with the
things that I've just spoken about
things I've read the things I've
listened to you from both sides on a
balanced view I will be supporting this
companies count your casting please
thank you very much yeah I've I did a
few calculators and calculations because
I was thinking about there's some feed
situation that Laurie's coming in with
the feed and I worked out I assume the
um the sheds are staggered
um they're not all the same age in the
sheds I yeah the um the the oldest ones
eating 160 grams per day the youngest
and then it going right down to um the
new ones eating 32 grams of food a day
there'd be a need of 30 just over 30
tons of feed to come into the site a day
which I think we've got to be careful
that we don't
get too excited about the impact of the
feed lorries coming in because that's
some that's one one Lorry a day and then
an extra one at the end of the week to
um to deal with that and that's at the
very very much the highest it will go
the um the um
this isn't this kind of industry is so
important because there's not a massive
margin to be made on this people want
cheap food and we'd love to have all
free-range Birds
um we can't possibly do that there's a
margin what that I believe of about 50p
per bird if you're lucky if things are
good on this so therefore to actually
produce food in this way we do need
these large-scale sheds I'm I'm really
pleased to hear that the um the space
allowance that you're looking to um
increase the space allowance that would
mean that it's of a better quality and a
better welfare standard of anything
we're importing shorter free range the
um
it and also what this brings to people
is the jobs also working on a average
consumption 34 grams per week per person
you'll this is producing about quarter
of a million people's annual consumption
of chicken which is is quite incredible
it's um the the numbers are looking
through this the numbers are absolutely
huge but I think this is necessary and
um with these large sheds as well a lot
of the problems that you see in the
smaller sheds like flies odor and
everything are actually a lot less in
the larger sheds because they're built
for purpose they're managed well and um
there's enough people to deal with it
that you know you're not stretching
um they're workers and they have time to
do absolutely everything and it's done
cyclically so um for me
I think this
is a this is just really needed
um
I've looked around on Google I've seen
how much of that type of business is
here it makes sense for it all to be in
the same place or a lot of it to be in
the same place and um I've got no I've
got no issue as long as this grampian
condition on a um
on a net zero water usage
or whatever the words are is um is
followed because that means that we're
not gonna we're not going to use any
more water on it it's sustainable on
that site for water usage but I'll let
the people that deal with that kind of
thing every day and know a lot more
about it than I know deal with that
um so as far as I'm concerned I'm I'm
happy with this application and I will
be looking to
propose approval of it
thank you very much can we have a second
to please
occasion Humphreys I'm sure happy to
Second for all the reasons with the
conditions set including that grumping
condition on water neutrality thank you
okay thank you very much thanks for
stringing I just want to uh just
elaborate on why I I won't be supporting
that in its in its current form uh we we
heard a definition of sustainability but
this is development control committee
and the definition of sustainable
development is that the development that
meets the needs of the present without
compromising the ability for future
generations to meet their own needs
if we don't get the water use right it
will fall at the first hurdle of
sustainable development
so that needs to be correct we've also
heard that the water supply will come in
but we don't we haven't actually been
demonstrated where from it'll either
fall out in the sky or it will come out
of a borehole or it will come in along
and all I was wanting to to have
confirmed is what combination of those
three will it be because if it's the
majority of the latter then that will
have an effect upon sustainability uh
and traffic use etc etc which is why I
wanted that information before I was in
the in in the position to make a rounded
decision thank you chair
Michelle thank you a lot to come back on
that thank you for that other Definition
of sustainability your absolute right in
development and this does provide for
the present and the future so it ticks
that box and I'd just like to confirm if
I could please because I'm second in
this I want to be right I want to make
sure I'm right for you councilor
stringer at the moment we're looking at
rainfall harvesting we're looking at the
Lagoon discipline enough water for that
that area is that true
that's correct there's no requirement
for water to be tankered in providing
additional vehicular movements above and
beyond the submitted transport statement
thank you very much does anyone else
wish to speak counter melon please
okay so
um I think this is
not a clear application in terms of
um
I've worked in in the poultry industry
in this area
um I accept that we're moving towards a
much more uh kind of efficient and uh
more welfare friendly sort of industry
in fits and starts and clearly it's
better that we have
local production than we have imports
from areas where we don't control the
kind of welfare standards
um
the two two major concerns for this
application and one is one is the impact
on the
uh on the highways Network
and the second one is is this concern
about the water so just to look at the
highways thing first
go back to the mppf we've got um
a very strong paragraph that we have to
get over which is you know you
development should only be prevented and
refused if there's an unacceptable
impact on highway safety or the residual
cumulative impacts on the road Network
would be severe
and we have to take the word of our
professional consultees very seriously
we don't have to accept it and swallow
it you know without common or without
examining it
um but you know the highways have said
that they don't think is a severe
problem clearly there's more Lorry
movements than just moving the feed into
this site this Lorry movements bringing
the raw materials to the mill there's
from the mill to the site there's uh
there's the the birds have got to be
coming in the bird's got to go out
the lit has got to go out straw and so
forth has got to come in or whatever
they use for bedding
so there's multiple different streams of
stuff coming in and out and obviously
water's got to be tanked away as well
and dealt with as well so it's not just
about the feed it's much wider than that
and these roads are not
are not wide they're not um
you know as the board member said you
know they're built for awesome car now
we've got hgvs rumbling up and down
so I do have a concern about that
um is it enough
does the mppf allow us to refuse
something on on that basis probably not
the water thing is is still
a real big question in my mind
if that Lagoon runs out they will be
clearly
taking water out of the water main
they're not going to tank correct we've
just heard that there's a water main
that feeds the existing facilities
and therefore if we do get into a
drought situation they will be putting
extra stress on the network to produce
that water which Anglia water Essex and
Suffolk water said there isn't the
capacity and there isn't the possibility
of a borehole because the aquifer can't
take it so I I I'm still really
concerned about that and I'm not
entirely convinced
that the grampian commission condition
is going to give us the answer that we
we really need the Surety I'd like
certainly like to see some more some
more information on that so I'm sort of
still ambivalent about this this
application uh some question marks in my
mind thank you Chet
thank you
thank you chair
um
a couple of things first first I got to
like everyone else I got a letter from
Davidson Farms which set out the um
economic
um
ramifications of this development
so we're aware of that uh the um
cranwick chickens I I I'm a little bit
confused by Council on for his
uh contribution about growth my
understanding was it wasn't so much
about growth but about improved welfare
conditions for the existing amount of
product you have
that's correct it's not make it it's not
more chickens overall it's about better
chickens
more space
um
so just to clarify that it's not that
growing but it's actually managing
what's there in a better way
the bits about the traffic and the what
particular water play the way that keeps
coming to my mind is stress there's only
so much stress any sort of system can
cope with
[Music]
um
you can stress the system to a certain
point and then it will break and this is
particularly true in traffic
um 4.7 sounds tolerable but it it might
be sort of moving towards a Tipping
Point where there's too much stress on
that road Network
we're already in um
a water stress environment and that
covers the whole of Suffolk
um 20 miles to the South you've got
sizeable C that was initially stopped by
the planet in spectrum because there was
no war there wasn't a sufficient fresh
water to either build the site nor
actually maintain it
that was overturned by the Secretary of
State
um in your final documents you mentioned
the grampian conditions and
the mitigation an update on the
mitigation expected this is Page 75
which may need this to be the subject of
a separate application
um
I I think I do need to see that
detail before I can wholeheartedly
support it we're in a stressed water
environment we've got housing
developments
throughout the region
and
this is
a site where there's a potential for
water harvesting which hasn't yet been
don't forget the pump tapped
um
there's three sites and then Crandall
chickens suppliers that do
practice water harvesting
so we could have information on how
successful that be has been and how that
is
achieved a water neutral production
cycle
so
I I do so it is a difficult situation
I'm very ambivalent I do support the
economic grounds for this the welfare
grounds for this
um but I do
not want to be in a situation of adding
to the stress of the water environment
by agreeing it without knowing the
details that it is feasible
um anecdotally last week there was a 90
chance of rainfall in melis
um not a drop film so that is
a worry about the sort of future of the
future water supply and that's where the
sustainability really hits in we've got
the grampian condition but I'd like to
see the detail before it went forward
Mr chair thank you I just come back on
the word growth I'm talking about
business growth which means expansion
which improves the product and that's
that's what he's doing thank you
um frankly because um we're being told
by all our Consultants that um that it's
okay and we're being assured by our our
own offices that um that everything is
under control and it's you know um and
and I know that people are concerned
about the water you know but but that's
why it's been conditioned if these
things cannot be achieved they will not
be able to continue
um I've lived within half a mile of this
site and um and I've never like I said
the roads actually
um although Judy says they might have
been built for horse and cop these are
actually pretty good roads and the only
road that is um with only worry really
is Chadbrook um village the primary
school there that is a narrow point that
there that is only for the feed and and
have you looked at that's only going to
be nine extra you know hdvs and um the
main road to dis and through everything
else is they're great roads and um
yeah I'm really happy with this so I'm
happy to support it
thank you I just wondered if um with
this grampian condition whether the um
legal team or anyone if if I could ask
them um if there's a way to strengthen
that at all
um I can hear what counselors want with
that condition and
um the more robust that condition
can be the better really for me but um
I think that the detail might be more
matter for my colleagues sitting in
front but sorry I'm
microphone
computer
it's always I think you've already
explained the matter whether a grampian
can
should be imposed and whether it is
likely to deliver the goods as it were
all be unlikely of achievement is a
matter of planning judgment which is a
matter for initiative and mass of making
the recommendation and then for
obviously for you laser
um yes I'm sure the officer will wish to
make it as robust as is reasonable and
is practically deliverable
thank you
yeah perhaps I can
um thank you chair so just having a look
at the condition there's a fair amount
covered in there in terms of making sure
that we've got the reservoir the
timeline for it to be filled how it's
going to be filled
um and that so there's quite a lot in
there I think in terms of adding what we
might be thinking is the detailed
information on how much water the
chickens need over time compared to
what's in the reservoir how long that
might last so we've got through all of
the background information so perhaps we
can give some more reassurance that
there is barely a fairly long lifespan
to it and to agree those details
um so I think perhaps um it might not be
something I could suggest we add to the
recommendation but the master and I
might need to take away to work into the
condition itself
yeah and I think if counselors want to
talk about that I'd be quite happy to
listen proposal thank you thanks for
Norris you wish to say something
um yes I have several concerns uh but
I'm not sure that there are sufficient
grounds to refuse this application I do
understand the
um position that someone of the
uh committee are taking regarding the
water supply but
this is a an unknown quantity to a
certain extent who can reliably predict
rainfall in the future I mean that ends
the water element itself sufficient
grounds to refuse this application
highways have said on pages 56 continue
to page 57 further to additional
correspondence and information from the
applicants Consultants of further site
visit consideration of The Proposal we
are no longer in a position to uphold an
objection on this proposal whilst The
Proposal will generate a modest increase
in hgv traffic
these are not at a level that we can
maintain an objection upon as having a
severe or unacceptable impact
reference to nppf treble one paragraph
it should also be noted that significant
parts of the identified Roots form Parts
Suffolk Lorry group network so I do
understand the concerns of local
residents but I don't think there are
sufficient grounds personally to refuse
this application
that is my position thank you all right
does anybody else wish to speak
no okay then I I will have my say now
um thank you very much to all the
contributors to this debate it's been
very very interesting
um I will be supporting this application
for accrual uh I fully agree with the
ward member we need to keep those local
jobs local for local people we need to
see businesses grow we need to consider
food security I do accept the point
about the water that I'm satisfied with
what the officers have said that that
can be dealt with so I will be
supporting this application uh if there
are no further questions I would ask the
governors also to go to the vote please
thank
thank you
thank you chair members at voters now in
progress
this item was originally 7c on the
agenda it will be down at the bottom of
your app
[Applause]
cancelable voice do you need me to take
your vote verbally
thank you chairs that is five votes for
and free against thank you very much so
that's Carrie thank you very much indeed
thank you
um I'd like to sort of wish have a 10
minute break
foreign
I'd now like to move on to item 7A
dc2101 457 Land north of pest House Lane
Barham and I now invite the case officer
Jasmine yr to introduce the application
to the committee thank you Jasmine
thank you chair and good morning members
I'm presenting a reserve matters
application today for the erection of 20
dwellings including seven affordable
units at land north of pest House Lane
Barham
Reserve matters are appearance
Landscaping layout and scale
members are reminded that this
presentation does not seek to replace
any of the information and detail within
the committee report it's solely to
provide an overview of the application
so in terms of the planning history on
the site and outline planning permission
was granted subject to conditions and a
section 106 agreement which secured the
affordable housing provision on site in
so here we have the site outlined in red
the A14 is located to the west and
you've got a variety of dwellings in
terms of their appearance and scale
located to the north and east of the
site with a more sporadic cluster of
development located south
there are a range of existing
small-scale buildings on site which you
can see shown by the kind of gray
rectangles
um with the existing access previously
approved under the outline to be
upgraded to serve this residential
development
in terms of site constraints the site is
wholly within flood zone one and there
are public rights away running along the
western and southern boundaries of the
site and the nearest list of buildings
are shown by the orange which is often
are to the north both of which are grade
two listed and comprise a public house
and Barham Lodge
so in terms of surface water and risk so
whilst the site is at a very low risk of
fluvial flooding which is the flood zone
one the site has a variety of pluvial
flood risk which is the surface water
flooding ranging from low to high so as
you can see the it's primarily at a low
risk but there are pockets of quite high
risk mostly to the western side of the
site
mm-hmm
so here's the site layout Plan and
there's adequate parking provision
provided for all units some of which is
within
um the garages that are provided on plot
a cycle and pedestrian cut through would
be created in the northeast corner of
the site improving the connectivity of
the site because this cut through would
bring users
um pretty much to the the bus stops
which run rug which run regular services
from them um which are located along
Norwich Road and sturgeon way
the development would be a cul-de-sac
type development entirely enclosed by
Soft Landscaping from Norwich Road and
pest House Lane as you can see along the
boundaries
um save for the parking and access to
each plot there's a mixture of grass
trees and hedgerows proposed internally
around the road and footways to the
frontage of the plots
and to resolve the surface water
flooding
issues on site as far as possible a
flood compensation storage area is
proposed to the western edge of the site
as you can see I don't know if the
mouse's working
but
um yeah so to the Western designers are
working
so in terms of the existing trees on
site
um there are a range of existing trees
dotted around some of which are proposed
for removal but these have all been
confirmed to be of a low value and the
removal is kept to a minimum certainly
all other trees are to be retained and
especially along the eastern boundary of
the site
um they're to be strengthened with new
planting
in terms of the elevations there are a
range of house types proposed across the
development all of which utilize similar
materials so I just run through three
examples
and as you can see there are the
traditional form with a modern
vernacular
and notably all of the affordable units
on site are tenu blind by where their
design and materials
these images give you an idea of the
overall Street Scene within this
cul-de-sac setting the built form would
be broken up by Soft Landscaping as I
mentioned earlier retaining a rural
character
and in terms of I've just got a few site
photos so the first photo on the left
just shows the existing redundant
buildings on site which should be
removed which you can kind of see in the
distance and this is taken from the
access point which was approved outline
and then along the right is where the
cut through would come out on again I
can't uh use the mouse at the minute I
don't know why but
um so in terms of where that cut through
would come out on it would be right at
the end of that road
um and this is along Norwich Road
then just in terms of the access point
uh so this is the left-hand photos
looking north um
sorry along pest House Lane and then
you've got uh towards
yeah East towards the other end of
pastel's Lane which then joins onto
Norwich Road
so the recommendation is therefore to
approve these Reserve matters for the
reasons set out in the kitchen report
thank you for listening thank you very
much Jasmine do we have questions please
for the planning officer counselor
having them please
a quick one can you put the the map of
the flooding with the high and low risk
on please
oh
some of them
some of the high risk is actually where
the houses are going to be
sorry
yes so far
I just think is it is some of the
housing on where it's high risk or is it
just you know can we not you can't see
both there will be a very small element
that is where some of the houses are and
I think the the key point which
hopefully comes through in the committee
report is that Suffolk County Council
floods and water they they are unable to
remove their holding objection
um this is based on the fact that it is
within their remit to deal with the
surface water flooding
um
outline permission was granted and we
have taken council's opinion on the the
kind of principle of development and
revisiting uh the flood risk yes so in
terms of uh I suppose finding the best
way forward with this
um we have saw external flood risk
device which does believe that the
dwellings would be as safe as they can
be for for their lifetime and in effect
doesn't increase flood risk elsewhere
um the way that surface water flooding
is modeled as well is is slightly is
sometimes to do with the Topography of
the site so it's not always you know you
can see a very small pocket of high-risk
flooding but it might not actually be
the only bit of the site if that makes
sense
okay thank you counselor Humphreys
please sure thank you whereabouts
through the affordable houses
there we go
um so I don't know if you can see
there's kind of labels here and here so
they're along here and here
um because it's only a development of 20
dwellings obviously it's quite a small
development anyway and they are in
obviously a kind of cluster on the site
but they're not exceeding the 15 that is
normally the guidance point and
obviously if it's only 20 dwellings then
any further questions please casual War
boys
thank you chair uh yeah yes um
I notice there's no response from Anglia
water and we've got actually sort of
asked
on
I mean this is a relatively small
development I suppose but we have our
Stanley of water that they produce
detailed
details of how they're going to manage
Wastewater from a site and where it's
going
I'm just wondering if it'd be
appropriate to put in the one of the
conditions that there's a sort of water
we've got a sustainable energy statement
and surface water could we have a water
management condition in there as well
so in terms of the the
fatter which is what angling water would
be dealing with
um they haven't provided comments on
this application but I think it's
because they possibly have missed some
of the information that was submitted
alongside the application and I have
since clarified with the
um agent that they are proposing to
connect to the mains and angling water
do have a statutory duty to make
capacity for the flows
um indeed if you if members wish to have
a condition which specifically details
details of foul water drainage to be
submitted that that could be imposed
that's that's not a problem
yes we've agreed this is the council
meeting as well
okay any further questions
not at all okay
right well we have
um no questions from any public speakers
we've got no objectors no supporters the
aid is not here but I do have a
statement a joint statement from the
Ward members
sorry
oh apology
you don't wish the speaker okay thank
you very much
okay
I'll read the war member statement this
is a joint statement from counselor's
Whitehead and councilor Passmore
thank you for the opportunity to submit
this Ward member statement on this
application
when I addressed the committee back in
March 2019 on the outline permission for
this site I concurred with the office
recommendation for approval
residents and Parish councils in my ward
are generally supportive of modest
infill sites such as this one in
contrast to the much larger and more
controversial applications that that
place an excessive strain on our local
infrastructure
in the case of this application I
support these Reserve matters with only
one concern that relates to the final
condition included in the officers
report that final condition removes all
permitted development rights on
extensions and outbuildings
some of these plots have large south
east or west facing Gardens and I
suspect many buyers of these properties
plots one to four and plots 15 to 20 may
want to enhance their properties in due
course with the addition of
conservatories garden rooms or garden
offices the committee may want to debate
whether this blanket removal of all
permitted development rights is a
reasonable condition to impose going
forward on those residents thank you
right so
we move into debate counter stream
please yep thank you chair uh yeah we're
looking at Reserve matters here on on a
scheme that already has outline approval
so to sort of go almost go back on the
the flooding issue is is would seem sort
of
thing already and also these flood maps
you do get odd little pockets where
there there's a there's an old midden or
an old pit or something will show up
that it could flood in that pocket but
in reality once this is built in
it won't because it's also substantial
amount of area for mitigation for
flooding in this scheme it's probably
one of the biggest I've seen I have to
say
congratulate that because they've
managed to orientate most of the roofs
so they can you know benefit from solar
gain in in the present or even future
I quite like the design being quite
modern without being Pastiche uh I quite
like the fact it's got no fake chimneys
on it the only thing I would seek to try
and beef up in this application would be
rather than looking at air source heat
pumps I'd actually like to see it you
know because in the absence of any other
sustainable technology at the moment uh
you know we're almost in that vhsb to
Max moment
if we could beef up the air source heat
pump thing I would move approval chair
thank you
thanks to Humphries
for sure thank you
um yeah I'm I'm going to move along this
same lines as Council Stringer obviously
on this one
um
the only comment I've got is what the
award member raised about the right for
people to extend
um
you get on the personal route on this
how would I feel and that's the rate I'm
going to take so how would I feel that I
move into a nice house it's got ample
room and my family gets bigger and I
like the sun and I want to build a
conservatory how would I feel if I want
to extend my house rather than move
because that's the most viable way of
doing it because it's too expensive to
move so for that I'd like to see the
removal of that condition or find a real
reason why it's in there thank you
yes so um the reason that it is actually
imposed is solely because of the flood
risk ordinarily
um permitted development rights are
normally removed on an outline
permission and they haven't been removed
on the outline permission uh obviously
we are where we are the reason that it's
removed for things like hard standing
means of enclosure and
extensions outbuildings is
an event anyone extending their house in
the future it just means that planning
permission would be required and the
reason for that is so that we can assess
that the flood risk is not increased
obviously if every one of those 20
dwellings decides that they want to
extend their property
it can have a cumulative impact in
isolation a single extension is probably
unlikely to have that that impact but
it's it's just to add that
additional element of of us being able
to check it
yeah sorry so thank you so um so it will
be written in when the person buys the
house somewhere in the contract would
say if you want to do it we're not
saying you can't but you'll need plan
permission yeah thank you brilliant
thank you
does anybody else wish to debate
accounts and custom please
yeah I think I'm following the line that
we're going in um yeah it seems for me I
now that it's been explained about the
permitted development rights I'm not
quite so worried about it
um I think um it is reasonably costly to
um get plan information for an extension
but we do see permitted development
extensions connecting storm water into
sewers and things like that so it does
make sense that we go through that
process and I understand that we could
end up having a lot more runoff on the
site than we expect if if it happens a
lot so I'm quite happy to um take
guidance from The Proposal and the
second for that
um
apart from that I think this issue with
air source heat pumps yeah I completely
agree with the proposer and um
if we can
strengthen that or say we want air
source heat pumps in there I think that
would be a lot more future proof
um so um I don't know what can be done
on that but I I'm happy to
um
agree with this agree with the proposer
now
um but I just take some guidance on
there and then see what the proposal in
the second to feel about
those two the permitted development and
the SLC pumps issue thank you um Jasmine
the F Source heat pumps would that be
possible to add as a condition or so I
think we we could build it into the
sustainability condition
um I think in terms of obviously the
applicant expressed that um you know
it's something that they'll be looking
to do anyway and a lot of this will I
don't know if the agent May
be able to I think it's a busy yeah if
it helps can you yes it would be
you come down to the chair in the front
please thank you
yes yeah it would it would be helpful if
you can clarify that position for us
thank you
um thank you chairman and um apologies
for sort of like abrupt
interjection
um yeah it's the way to go and uh I
think um
we would uh we and the uh the applicant
would be very happy to accept that as a
condition it's
it's happened
thank you that's much appreciate it
thank you
yeah just to sum up yeah I I like this I
like the affordable housing that's in
there and I like the fact that it's
walking distance from a co-op
um it it's a good application so yeah
I'll be voting for The Proposal thank
you do both the proposal and the second
or are they both happy with the
inclusion of the condition of air
sourcing pumps yep thanks for war boys
please
thank you chair
um I'm quite I'm quite happy with the
the
the that those uh just followed from
Council caxon's remarks about the sort
of sewage and uh rainwater runoff could
we just have the Water Management
condition included as well
um what sort of water management is it a
specific
are you are we looking at kind of foul
water just because if we're relating it
to flood risk matters
the the kind of sud strategy has been
extensively worked up and I don't think
that there's any more we can do in terms
of the actual surface water flooding if
it's more to do with the foul water we
can certainly get details of it but they
have confirmed that they are to connect
to the the mains and through angling
water
yeah yeah and
I I was thinking well it's the topic
this today
um but this is a domestic situation we
could actually look at some brown Water
Harvest and rainwater harvesting in
order to sort of
um
mitigate against it
surface runoff and
I think that's certainly covered within
um the sustainability measures
conditioners are kind of standard
condition
about water efficiency measures and so
that's certainly something we can we can
emphasize further in that condition I
think what efficiency measures
covers it thank you
okay so Madam please
um generally happy with most things on
this application I will just point out
as councilor War boys raised it earlier
that we did pass
a motion back in November at the council
unanimously and the fourth point of that
was that planning officers from now
women's include in all reports relating
to major development a specific section
on on the impact on water courses
including the potential for the
development to result in untreated
sewage outflow into water courses or to
flag if this information is not fully
available so that the lack of
information is clearly and transparently
set out
I mean I I will be asking
regularly for for this to be included
with we decided as a council that's what
the information we want to see it's not
here in the report all we've got is
anglian water no comment
um so I don't feel that fits what we
agreed as a council in a change to our
procedure maybe one for for Gemma rather
than the new um but uh anyway I just
want to make that point it won't stop me
voting for this one but I would like to
see that information in future
does anyone else be push the comment at
all in the debate
no well I must admit I will be
supporting this application
um therefore we know how to propose and
a second or so could I ask the
governor's officer please to go to the
electronic vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
thank you chair that is eight votes for
status unanimous thank you very much
indeed thank you very much Jasmine
so I'd like to move straight on to the
next one I'll give a few minutes for the
changeover
if you've only watched a quick five
minute break please feel free the
changeover's done
I'll resume it um
foreign
field industrial estate iroad groom ip23
8aw and I now like to invite the case
officer Daniel Cameron to introduce the
application to committee please thank
you Daniel
thank you chair
um members might
remember a previous application on this
site dc21 uh
it was a dc21 application and the actual
number escapes me but I'll come to it
when I get to it in the report this is
for an erection of a B8 storage building
on iaf field you'll see from the plans
it is directly adjacent to the other 10
B8 storage buildings have been erected
on our Airfield
this is the aerial map of the site you
can see
communication site outlined in purple
and orange with the other various
ba storage uses
lined here there's some pole barns
storage related to agriculture located
just off here we've got
slightly wider view you can see the edge
of the axley
thrandiston Brewing up from the North
and then the very edge of eye as well
with regards to constraints there aren't
too many we've got a grade two listed
building off to the West some distance
away and we have a footpath that
connects into this Bridal way
comes down runs down the side of the
a140 and then makes Connection in here
it runs adjacent to the site but not
within it and you'll see from the plans
the provision is made to not obstruct
the root of the um the footpath and then
this continues across the Airfield
during the site visit there's a gap in
the protective fencing around the edge
and a bridge over the ditch to allow
pedestrians to cross over I have noted
the comments from
the British Hall society and their
desire to upgrade it to a bridal way
however we've also consulted the public
rights of way team who'd be responsible
for the maintenance and the upgrading
works and they haven't made any
suggestions that they would like to see
the upgrades made
um
case it would bring
horse users into conflict with quite
heavy traffic on the a140 so it's not
seen to be
desirable in this instance there are no
table papers before you members and we
have the report before you I do have an
update to the recommendation and I will
come to that presently
in terms of objections we have room and
Oakley Parish councils want to see the
footpath signed and maintained and like
um pollution Capital minimum the public
footpath is already signed and
maintained with regards to thranistan he
actually concern has raised about
additional floor space being created on
iaf field and potential impacts of
flood waters on those Villages and we
also have a holding injection from the
flood and water team I had hoped to be
in a position to give a verbal update to
memos on their position unfortunately
the water engineer was involved in a
public inquiry in the past couple of
weeks and it's behind on responses I did
speak to them informally they would
quite like to see the additional
information they've asked for come
forward from the applicant and I will be
ensuring that comes forward and
therefore the recommendation before
members would be altered to delegate
authority to the chief planning officer
to Grant plan permission on the Proviso
that the flood and water team are happy
and are content that we go ahead um in
all other respects we have no other
objections from statutory consultees or
representations from Neighbors speaking
to um
object to the application
if we have a look at the oh site plan
we've got some existing Suds features
off to the west and it's proposed that
these be extended and improved as they
were for the additional applications to
the north when they came forward
um
in total we're looking at a 1.49 hectare
site but some of that is taken up with
the access
to the site such the actual footprint of
the building is smaller it measures
114.9 meters in length
45.6 meters in width and 11.4 meters to
the Ridge and 8 meters to its Eaves I'll
show you the site photos later on but
the materials and the design proposed to
match the other B8 storage buildings on
site importantly there are no industrial
processes proposed to be going on within
the building it's purely for storage
we have no planned equipment machinery
air conditioning um the building we only
have lighting
and the building lighting is to be
powered by the wind turbines on site
such that it should be
powered 100 by renewable sources except
for days when the third ones are
incapable of producing electricity
um
you can see here the boundary fencing
on one side on the previously approved
building we then have this run of
Hedgerow that's proposed to maintain and
this is the run of the public footpath
between so it would always be open and
able to be
um
accessed
see the wind turbine in those pole barns
mentioned earlier in the background
and then here we have the view back up
to the access
um so it's proposed um gray cladding
um with red detailing
um with regards to the first application
members will remember that that was
located in hartsman Water Resource Zone
this application is located in the same
Zone as well with regards to that it's
explained in more detail in the report
um
but the the concluding points are that
while the use is non-domestic there is
no water supply proposed within the
building if we jump back to the
floor plan there's no
um staff Brake Area there's no toilet
area
um
even if there were those users would
likely be seen as akin to domestic by
Essex and Suffolk water
um
and therefore
could have those in here if they were
required but
we have no water resource coming into
this site whatsoever so therefore the
building itself is water neutral
of its in terms of its use there are
other facilities for staff working on
site provided Elsewhere on the site so
they don't need to be provided
provided here and on that basis we don't
need the same grampian condition because
we
members will know that the final section
of the report we have included a
condition that states the use of the
building will be B8 storage only
that just protects the council in a
similar way that the condition on the
previous application did with regards to
flood risk and extension to those
properties this will prevent a change of
use to bring a manufacturing process
that required water into the site
without a planning application therefore
we'd be able to make sure that we have
those water neutrality details either
present within the application or could
require them via grumping condition as
we did with the first application
I'll pass back over to members I'll take
questions that may have Arisen as a
result of the report and I'll look to
support you in any debates that you have
going forward thank you very much Daniel
over to you members who would like to
kick off the questions
character stringers that you'll have
right I'm just trying to find the this
is one of the problems with having so
little in the documentation right I've
now found it okay uh we have a policy
that says if a if a uh non-domestic
building is more than a thousand square
meters it shall then you know produce
energy uh you suggested it was going to
be connected to the wind turbines that
are on site but they're not part of the
application
they're not in the site area so
therefore why are we not conditioning
solar panels on the roof of this
building
if members feel that that would be
appropriate that's completely within the
scope of their decision making powers to
include that should they want to support
the amended recommendation as I've
verbally given it to them
um
we could do
um the applicant said that the
provision from the wind turbines should
be sufficient to power the building it's
a very low power building itself in
terms of there's limited external
lighting and internally the lighting
would only be
utilized during working hours
um but if members felt that that was
appropriate then
could move forward with the condition
but yeah I mean the application is just
around the building in its perimeter and
its access they could flog it off
tomorrow there's no such yeah we
couldn't guarantee that would be in
place we have a policy that says you
know that's what building should do if
they're non-domestic so this building
isn't doing it it's just tacking onto
existing renewable energy that happens
to be on site that is due to come down I
think in 12 years time now isn't it
because they're only there for a short
period of turbots they had a 20 odd year
license and they so uh yeah personally
I'd like to see as that hold that policy
because we've been I think someone
inconsistent with that policy in the
past I think we should uphold it
okay any further questions
well we have no speakers at all nothing
from the Ward member so therefore I'll
open up the item for debate
who'd like to kick off the debate
going to cast it
say something for the sake of it then um
yeah I this is the right place for this
type of warehouse and it's um there's
very little harm that's going to be
caused by um putting it there the space
is there it makes sense to have this
these some all in the same place jobs
wise I don't you know I don't know
exactly how many jobs it delivers but
it's all good it a knock-on effect as
well throughout
um mid-suffolk
um having that facility
um
the only thing that I think
we need to be talking about is what
counts the Stringer said about the solar
panels because
um he's right it is policy we should be
doing it I um
I wouldn't like to see solar panels put
on there that aren't
connected to um you know aren't being
aren't useful because obviously they in
the manufacturer and in in putting them
there there's a certain amount of cost
to the environment and um you know
shipping and everything like that but um
I do understand I think he makes a very
good case and what what the question is
is because it's policy do we just do it
because it's policy which I'm sure if
they've got power coming off there
they'll do something with it or they'll
do something with the wind turbine power
generated
um but I just yeah I'm sort of a bit on
the fence about that I don't want to see
solar panels that aren't needed but also
I think
councilor string is right every if if
that's the policy that's what we should
be asking for and um
that's that's what we should be getting
the policy is that it should generate I
think it's 20 of its own energy use uh
from non from renewable sources it
doesn't it it's not specific but we we
do spend in an ordinary amount of time
here deciding where solar panels should
or should not go uh and we have a policy
that says the first place they should go
is on the roof of non-domestic buildings
so what I'm suggesting is if we want to
release the pressure from agricultural
land we need to start standing up and
putting them on our commercial buildings
and this is one such building and I I
would be happy to Second an approval on
this sort of support the approval if it
had a condition that meant an element of
solar power went on this Brew thank you
thank you very much so yeah I totally
agree with what you're saying but it's
it's really limited by the
infrastructure that we've got there and
where you know the cables in the ground
because you know for me this would be
great if this whole place turned into a
solar farm but you need to have the
connection the grid connection and it
needs to be of a capacity to take it and
we don't really know
hmm
well um
yeah in in my world I think you'd
definitely apply for a connection and
turn that into a solar Farm um but um
yeah I don't know I don't I don't really
know enough about the electrical
infrastructure there to say that it
would definitely be
useful okay Daniel then every character
War boys just to help members in their
debate we do have a condition
um suggested
um such as we get submission of a scheme
of Auto energy and resource efficiency
measures for the construction and
operational phase that could be
um amended in its word and to include
delivery of PV within building 11. so
that could be a way forward if that
helps members resolve this question
thank you Daniel uh calcular warbles
please
yes thank you chair I think I was just
good to come on Council Stringer said in
council tax in terms of a site
uh there's a proposed gas powered
station they're building
um
gas capacitor
facility across the road uh does it
existing
uh Power Station which burns it doesn't
burn chicken litter anymore it burns
wood
so this will be an ideal site I should
imagine for not just on this site but
actually sort of building as cancer
Cactus solar farm which should save uh
building a similar
size capacity on
agricultural land
um
so I I'm quite happy to support this
application I think the the existing
buildings and the the proposed finishes
the delivery it is a it is a quality
um
site um
so and this would carry on I I quite
nice to see it aligned with the rest of
the buildings but I understand to get
that size of building on the site that
would have to be tilted otherwise you
lose that amount of space it's good to
see that the footpath is emphasized
um I agree with the officer I think that
upgraded it to a bridal way would
without some concerns there's particular
horses Crossing the
the main road
um so I think I think it's an excellent
um
proposal and I'd like to propose to
accept it with the added
recommendation as the account as the
officer said about that we we beef up
the Energy Efficiency we've noted
there's electrical vehicle charging
points and that the site should be at
least self-sufficient by the use of
filter but take cells if not an actual
net energy producer
Humphries
so yeah I will support this and I'll
definitely second that proposal I think
we need to beef it up a little bit
though um we've turned down solar panel
Farms on agricultural lands for all the
reasons and during those debates and
I've been party to them we've actually
said we should be using old hangers new
warehouses whatever it might be of this
massive
massive area that we can use and get it
off the ground and here's the ideal
opportunity so what I would like from
the offices if the proposer is an
agreement is that we need a very beefy
recommendation almost a condition that
is a condition to State that's what we
want
um let's not say we'd like it it's what
we want it's what we need and that's
what we should have
so um so I'd like you if you could just
to work on that if you're happy Roland
yeah no I I completely agree with that I
think there's a it's it's quite
complicated because you need to apply
for a great connection and I assume
they're owned by different people so
you'd you'd want to encourage a
Consortium maybe to get together get the
grid connection and do it which
you'd think that it would be an absolute
like no-brainer for them to do if we if
we're looking at solar Farms on land and
people are willing to pay money for
hectares of land with solar panels on
you'd think that this would just make
make it make money but um I think um I'd
like to hear what officers
think that would look like because I'm
quite happy for this to be an officer
delegated you know the will of this
committee is for it to be a um net
producer of electricity but um it's
obviously extremely complicated to um to
do that with this one planning
application this red line and um and
where we are
thank you chair
um yeah what I would probably suggest is
that we look to clarify the
sustainability condition and that it
includes a requirement of solar panels
the issue we've got slightly is that we
can only require the 10 per the policy
so
I would leave it open to a degree in the
condition that I'm doing quite a total
requirement for solar panels and if we
get more that's what we can support as
officers if we only get the 10 we
couldn't refuse it but we know that
we're securing at least that by the
solar panels and if they come in with
more we can support that if problems are
content with that
yes yeah I think it sets a very good
precedent that we can then use in the
future to support other applications and
I think that's part of the reason we
need to push this so yeah thank you
I'd just like to say it's obviously not
a planning committee but I think
mid-suffolk exactly what they should be
doing is facilitating this kind of thing
to happen it may outside of the planning
process but um with economies we should
definitely be looking this is this is
the perfect site to do something like
that and if mid-suffolk could help with
that in any way I think that's what we
should be looking at doing but yeah now
I'm happy with the proposal and yeah
happy to vote for it yes thank you yes I
too are very happy with this application
I totally support the amendment that
came to Stringer actually raised in the
first place so if no one else wishes to
speak I will ask the governance officer
to go to the electronic boat or did you
want Gemma did you want to read out the
well it's just we had a tweak from the
recommendation compared to the paper so
I just wanted to clarify please yep so
we're delegating to the chief planning
officer to confirm surface water
drainage with Suffolk County Council
floods and water subjects list or
previous recommendations on pages 44 to
45 including any conditions regressive
by Suffolk County Council floods water
and with verification that the
sustainability condition includes a
requirement for certain panels
thank you very much everyone happy with
that
thank you very much
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
thank you chair that is seven votes for
statute levels thank you very much
indeed
um I'd like to be on item 8 site
inspections
none received here thank you very much
well the next meeting of the development
control B committee will be on the 29th
of March 2023 so I know formally closed
the meeting at 1204. thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen thank you for your
time this morning